>>> THIS MORNING ON "THE DISH"
IN A CITY OF EVER-CHANGING
FAVORITES, IL BUCO HAS STOOD THE
TEST OF TIME AS ONE OF NEW
YORK'S MOST BELOVED RESTAURANTS
AND IT'S THE INSPIRTION FOR A
COOKBOOK.
THE WOMAN BEHIND BOTH, AUTHOR
DONNA LENNARD.
OUR NANCY CHEN PAID HER A VISIT
AT A PLACE WHERE SIMPLE, FRESH
FOOD MAKES THE CLOCK TICK A
LITTLE SLOWER, EVEN BEFORE THE
FIRST BITE.
>> DONNA, EVEN COMING HERE, THE
COBBLESTONES PUT YOU IN THE
RIGHT MINDSET FOR ARRIVING.
>> IT MAKES THIS A REALLY
SPECIAL LITTLE ENCLAVE.
THERE AREN'T THAT MANY
COBBLESTONE STREETS LEFT IN NEW
YORK.
>> Reporter: WHEN DONNA LENNARD
OPENED IL BUCO 26 YEARS AGO, ITS
LOCATION WAS ALREADY
CHARACTERIZED BY A STORIED PAST.
>> IT WAS RUMORED THAT EDGAR
ALAN POE WAS INSPIRED BY THE
WINE CELLAR DOWNSTAIRS TO WRITE
HIS FAMOUS STORY ABOUT A
GENTLEMAN WHO IS PODANTIC ABOUT
HIS WINE AND HIS, QUOTE UNQUOTE,
FRIEND BRINGS HIM DOWN AND
BURIES HIM INSIDE A WINE CAVE.
>> Reporter: BUT IT'S WHAT'S
BEING CRAFTED ABOVE, THE FRESH
DISHES SIMPLY PREPARED BUT
BRIMMING WITH TASTE THAT HAS
MADE IL BUCO SO CHERISHED.
>> WHAT INFLUENCES THE FOOD
HERE?
>> WE'RE NOT STRICTLY TIED TO A
SPECIFIC REGION, EVEN IF UMBRIA
IS OUR INSPIRATION.
WE REALLY JUST LOVE GOOD FOOD
MADE WITH THE BEST INGREDIENTS
WE CAN FIND.
>> Reporter: A NETWORK OF
PRODUCERS AND HARVESTERS, SALT
MINES MERE SICILY, OLIVE GROEFZ
IN THE HEART OF ITALY AND
ORCHARDS IN UPSTATE NEW YORK.
A STARK EVOLUTION FROM THE
BEGINNINGS AS AN ANTIQUE STORE
IN 1993.
>> HOW'S THE PAELLA.
>> SO GOOD.
>> Reporter: LENNARD WAS BAR
TENDING WHEN SHE MET HER
PARTNER.
>> MY CRAZY PARTNER, ALBERTO,
WHO WANTED TO EITHER MOVE BACK
TO EUROPE OR EXPORT AMERICANA TO
SPAIN AND ITALY.
WE STARTED GOING TO ANTIQUE
FAIRS AND COLLECTED THINGS UNTIL
OUR APARTMENT WAS OVERFLOWING.
>> Reporter: IN NEED OF MORE
SPACE, SHE CAME ACROSS WHAT WAS
AN ARTIST'S STUDIO.
>> THEY DECIDED TO LEAVE THE
SPACE, GAVE OUR NAME TO THE
LANDLORD AND WE TOOK OVER TO
MAKE THE STORE HERE.
>> Reporter: THE TWO SET UP
THEIR SHOP BEFORE EMBARKING ON
WHAT THEY CALLED A BAR WITH WINE
SELLING ANTIQUES.
>> YOU HAD TO CONVINCE THE
LANDLORD TO DO THIS?
>> WE INVITED THEM TO LUNCH.
THEY WALKED IN AND SAW WHAT WE
DID AND WERE BOWLED OVER AND
SAID WHATEVER YOU WANT.
>> YOU CONVINCED THEM WITH FOOD.
>> WITH FOOD.
>> Reporter: SIMPLE AND MUCH OF
IT DISCOVERED BY HER PARTNER WHO
HAS SINCE MOVED BACK TO ITALY.
>> SIMPLE, WELL SOURCED
INGREDIENTS OF THE SEASON
TREATED WITH AS LITTLE AS
POSSIBLE AND MAYBE ONCE IN A
WHILE A LITTLE SOMETHING THROWN
IN THAT DOESN'T OVERWHELM BUT
ENHANCES WHAT YOU'VE ALREADY GOT
ON THE PLATE.
ALMOST EVERYTHING ON THIS TABLE
SPEAKS TO THAT.
>> Reporter: LIKE HER FAVORITE,
ANCHOVY TOAST.
THE ANCHOVIES STRAIGHT FROM
ITALY, SET ON TOP OF FRESHLY
BAKED BUCKWHEAT BREAD.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE AFTER?
>> A LITTLE BIT OF POTATO, A
TOUCH OF BECHAMEL.
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL CARROTS JUST
ROASTED AND CRISPY AND DELICIOUS
AND CARAMELIZED.
THEN GO INTO THE GAMBAS.
>> Reporter: THAT ARE THESE GULF
SHRIMP SEARED IN SALT.
>> THAT'S A VERY SIMPLE SALAD
WITH A LITTLE PEPPER AND BOTARGA
FOR ANYONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW IS A
VERY SPECIFIC INGREDIENT.
IT HAS THIS INCREDIBLE TEXTURE,
ALMOST LIKE SLICING INTO CHEESE.
>> Reporter: IF A TASTE OF
CHEESE IS WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR, ONE OF IL BUCO'S STARS IS A
DISH THAT WAS REFINED BY TWO OF
HER CHEFS AND THE TABLE
CENTERPIECE, RIBEYE SERVED WITH
ARUGALA AND SMOKED SALT.
>> IT'S DRESSED WITH A VERY AGED
BAL
BALSALMIC VINEGAR.
SITTING LOOKING AT THIS TABLE
FEELS LIKE A REFLECTION OF WHAT
WE DO AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR A LONG TIME AND HOPEFULLY
CONTINUE.
>> Reporter: HER SECOND
RESTAURANT OPENED IN 2011.
ANOTHER SOON FOLLOWED.
A JOURNEY LAID OUT IN LENNARD'S
RECENT BOOK.
>> YOU WRITE IN YOUR BOOK ABOUT
HOW IL BUCO ISN'T A PLACE, IT'S
A FEELING.
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
EXPERIENCE WHEN YOU COME HERE.
>> WHEN YOU COME FOR DINNER IT'S
LIKE BEING IN SOMEBODY'S HOUSE
WHERE YOU'RE REALLY JUST
CONVERSING WITH FRIENDS ABOUT
WHATEVER COMES UP AND REALLY
ENJOYING DELICIOUS FOOD AND
WINE.
>> Reporter: A HOME WHERE OLD
FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES PITCH IN.
>> HEY, EVERYBODY.
>> Reporter: STAFF HAS EVOLVED
INTO FAMILY.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD.
>> WHAT'S COOKING?
>> Reporter: AND CUSTOMERS HAVE
BECOME PARTNERS.
>> HI!
>> Reporter: AN ORGANIC MOSAIC
OF EXPERIENCES.
>> IT'S THAT FEELING THAT COMES
FROM CONNECTING.
>> CONGRATULATIONS!
>> WITH PEOPLE, WITH FOOD, WHERE
FOOD COMES FROM AND THE PEOPLE
THAT PRODUCE IT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
REALLY ENJOY WHEN THEY'RE HERE.
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING SATURDAY" NANCY CHEN,
NEW YORK.
>> GREAT JOB, NANCY.
AND NANCY GOT THE MEMO.
YOU DO "THE DISH" YOU BRING
FOOD.
>> IT LOOKS AMAZING.
>> TAKE A TASTE.
>> DELICIOUS.
>> JEFF IS OUR TASTE TESTER.
>> ALSO LIKE DONNA SAID THE
RESTAURANT IS LIKE FAMILY.
WE MISS THAT WITH SUCH DISTANCE
THIS PAST YEAR.
>> IT'